[Musique]
la robotique est aujourd'hui partout
elle s'est aussi répandue au sein des
armées dans tous les milieux à côté des
drones aériens ce sont désormais les
robot terrestres et sous-marins qui se
développent et pour des missions de plus
en plus variées du soutien à la
logistique de l'observation à la
détection de la surveillance à l'appui
au combat les robots sont un gamme
changer ils vont permettre de changer
l'art de faire la guerre la robotique
des gènes devrait permettre
d'éloigner l'homme de la menace elle
devrait aussi permettre de démultiplier
ses capacités la vraie question
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est une
évolution ou est-ce que ça va être une
révolution
la robotisation des armées est en marche
mais jusqu'où ira-t-elle à quoi
ressemblera le champ de bataille de
demain moins d'humains et plus de robots
la guerre finira-t-elle par être menée
par des machines autonomes autant de
bouleversements qui posent question
pour nous point de salut sans part de
l'humain dans la décision effectivement
il y a des questions éthiques abyssales
qui se posent
en intervention les sapeurs-pompiers de
Paris sont souvent épaulés par Colossus
un collègue d'un genre un peu
particulier un robot d'extinction
employé dans des conditions parfois
extrêmes avec un objectif éloigné
l'homme du danger le tout premier
exemple en service en 2017 à
Issy-les-Moulineaux l'un des trois
centres de secours spécialisés dans
l'exploration longue durée le principal
intérêt des robots c'est vraiment
envoyer le robot en cas de risque
d'effondrement d'éboulement ou de grosse
chaleur ou le sapeur-pompier serait
beaucoup trop exposé à un risque et en
espérant bah justement que il n'y ait
pas de mort par la suite aujourd'hui ce
robot il est indispensable dans notre
manière d'intervenir on pourrait
difficilement revenir en arrière c'est
un matériel de qualité qui a fait ses
preuves
à raison de 65 départs en intervention
par an en moyenne le robot est
régulièrement engagé sur des incendies
c'est aussi un engin de reconnaissance
avec ses capteurs il voit à 360 degrés
de jours comme de nuit et détecte les
gaz et produit toxiques cette machine
également adaptée au transport de
victimes et de matériel
représente une charge énorme on est sur
presque plus de 200 kg à apporter donc
réparties sur sur les personnels bien
sûr mais à côté de ça s'il porte 200 kg
sur des longues distances
automatiquement ils sont plus fatigués
pour commencer à faire leur mission donc
c'est pour préserver le pompier pour
être fort dans l'action à l'instant T
le robot pour être plus fort mais aussi
plus rapide
le robot mais une minute pour sortir de
l'engin et les engins comme les premiers
intervenants sont déjà garés on se
retrouve avec des rues bloquées donc
notre Intel il est sur le robot on peut
monter sur le trottoir et aller
rapidement sur les lieux de
l'intervention et s'engager au plus vite
parce que le facteur temps est important
la robotique terrestre au service du
combattant une histoire qui date au 20e
siècle déjà des ingénieurs français
conçoivent quelques machines comme cette
torpille destinée à transporter des
explosifs dans les tranchées ennemis à
l'époque de la Grande Guerre avec plus
ou moins de succès
parmi les plus abouties le Goliath
fabriqué par les Allemands au cours de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale
[Musique]
la robotique c'est peu à peu développé
en parallèle des conflits armés
le 11 septembre 2001 l'Amérique est
foudroyée par les attentats du World
Trade Center le pays le plus puissant du
monde se voit ainsi fragilisé par le
terrorisme
un des éléments marquants de
l'introduction des robots dans les
armées ce sont les guerres en Irak et en
Afghanistan
du début du 21e siècle avec notamment
l'apparition chez les insurgés de
d'engins explosifs improvisés et ces
engins explosifs improvisés laissés sur
le bord de la route qui explosait au
passage d'une unité militaire ami ont
causé énormément de dégâts aux forces de
la coalition notamment les militaires
français presque 1 sur 2 malheureusement
dans ces conflits ont été tués au
blessés par ces enjeux
il a fallu nécessairement trouver des
solutions et celles qui est apparue très
naturellement c'est le robot qui permet
de se déporter de se déplacer et d'aller
voir une menace potentielle d'aller
creuser le sol prendre des photos
analyser les images et détecter si
effectivement il y avait un agent
explosif improvisé sur le bord de la
route
dans les armées les démineurs sont
considérés comme les précurseurs de
l'utilisation de robot terrestres en
opération parmi eux le capitaine Florent
en près de 40 ans de carrière il a
participé à beaucoup d'opérations en ex
République yougoslave de Macédoine avec
le 17e régiment du génie parachutiste
comme le montre ses images tournées en
1999 mais aussi au Cambodge en Bosnie au
Liban et au Kosovo en Afghanistan en
Irak et en Syrie et plus récemment au
Mali les premiers idées sérieux que sur
lesquels j'étais confronté si on a rien
à distance où là là vraiment la
technologie et les techniques utilisées
par les paliers de mie était vraiment de
très haut niveau
ils forment désormais les gènes des
mineurs toute armée confondues au
désamorçage et à l'élimination de tous
les engins explosifs industriels ou
artisanaux ainsi qu'à l'emploi des
robots de déminage comme celui-ci
l'Afghanistan donc le combat de contact
il nous fallait un robot léger maniable
rapide qui puisse donc tout de suite
faire une intervention au profit des
démineurs et de l'infanterie et de la
manœuvre lors d'une embuscade par
exemple et nous avons également un robot
plus lourd qui nous permettra de faire
d'autres types d'intervention que ça
soit sous le territoire national mais
également une opération extérieure
un outil dont il ne peut plus se séparer
je suis devenu addict à ces deux engins
parce que dans l'équipe le robot bah
c'est lui qui va y aller en premier
c'est la première question que je me
pose face à une menace comme si là par
exemple la première question que je me
pose c'est est-ce que le robot peut y
aller à ma place c'est son boulot c'est
son job nous aussi on a l'autre et s'il
peut pas y aller pour des raisons
diverses et variées du genre
accessibilité
dangerosité de tir direct par exemple
ou tout simplement
l'approche est difficile puisqu'il y a
des fils piège donc là le robot il peut
pas Neutra des infilt piège ou un
plateau de pression donc là
effectivement on va faire notre travail
on va y aller mais tout d'abord c'est
lui s'il ne peut pas on va pas le mettre
de côté on va quand même l'utiliser soit
et vous nous aider à porter du matériel
soit il fait se mettre en position de
façon à pouvoir nous filmer et qu'on
soit en connexion directe avec notre
équipier qui reste soit au niveau du
véhicule blindé soit au niveau du camion
comme si le robot et nos démineurs c'est
un tout il fait partie intégrante de
l'équipe
depuis 20 ans les robots du génie ont
largement évolué aujourd'hui une
nouvelle génération fait son apparition
plus agile et embarquant davantage de
technologie comme les engins explosifs
ne cessent de se diversifier il faut
utiliser des capteurs là aussi
diversifiés pour
maximiser les chances de les détecter et
donc on peut avoir par exemple des
capteurs qui vont détecter plutôt
l'électronique des capteurs qui vont
détecter des changements dans le sol et
on cherche même à fusionner les
informations qui proviennent des
différents capteurs
c'est l'exemple du RSM de l'entreprise
Nantes capacité soutenue par l'agence de
l'innovation de défense un robot de
détection de mines antipersonnelles à
faible signature magnétique dont
l'utilité sera temps militaire en temps
de conflit que civil pour restituer des
terrains sécurisés aux populations
nous avons proposé d'associer de
l'intelligence artificielle et de la
robotique
dans une interface de collaboration avec
les démineurs cette interface permet
d'analyser les données qui sont
recueillies par le robot et d'aider le
démineur à prendre des décisions à
distance tout en sécurité alors
aujourd'hui on a une évolution de la
philosophie de l'autonomie dans la
robotique on a longtemps cru qu'on
allait mettre des robots à la place des
hommes aujourd'hui il s'agisse surtout
de mettre des robots avec les hommes et
de pouvoir les faire collaborer donc
c'est un robot et un homme plus qu'un
robot à la place de l'homme
ce robot utilise plusieurs techniques de
la mesure de contact de la mesure sans
contact et du radar de sol toutes les
données recueillies sont stockées et
géolocalisées puis analyser pour
l'instant aucun système ne permet
d'avoir cette approche mixant ces
différentes technologies
donc le robot peut travailler sur des
sous-munitions qui arrivent par voie
aérienne c'est sous-munitions donc sont
posées au sol peuvent être légèrement
dissimulées sous du feuillage et là le
robot peut avancer de lui-même par
analyse d'image il va détecter la
sous-munition qui est présente et
s'arrêter lui-même pour prévenir le
démineur à distance
le robot c'est aussi détecter les mines
enterrées et les dissocier des objets
naturels ils sont ne le sol en toute
autonomie libérant le démineur des
tâches répétitives pénibles et
dangereuses
en mer a même combat chaque année plus
de 2000 munitions sont détruites par les
plongeurs des mineurs dans cette guerre
des mines la Marine nationale elle aussi
mise sur la robotique pour renouveler et
moderniser ses capacités
[Musique]
c'est l'objectif du slames le premier
programme de drone naval pour la France
développé en coopération avec la
Grande-Bretagne alors Fabien Frédéric
s'est exploitation de mission ça donne
quoi
on est en train de regarder la dernière
mission là qu'on a fait sur raspace donc
c'est des rails d'un demi nautique de
longueur et 300 mètres de clocher
le but de la mine c'est d'interdire le
passage maritime l'accès et rapport
l'accès à un détroit et le système de
lutte contre les mines et bien c'est le
bouclier contre cette menace les mines
deviennent de plus en plus intelligentes
de plus en plus furtive donc la menace
évolue
plusieurs pistes ont été explorées par
la Direction générale de l'armement avec
les industriels certaines technologies
ont été retenues d'autres non
typiquement pour la neutralisation on
avait imaginé un drone kamikaze ce choix
n'a pas été fait pour le slamèche
l'idée c'est quand même même si on veut
éloigner l'homme de la menace c'est
important de garder l'homme dans la
boucle en permanence et pour les
fonctions
identification et neutralisation de
mines
le choix d'un Rohff donc un robot philo
guidé piloté par le marin à distance a
été fait le prototype qui préfigure le
système final est aujourd'hui en cours
d'évaluation opérationnelle par la
Marine nationale avec un objectif
vérifiez s'il répond bien aux besoins et
identifier les ajustements éventuels
avant livraison des premiers de séries
en 2024
[Musique]
on a fait un choix de prendre un drone
de surface habitable donc pendant toute
la phase d'évaluation en fait j'ai
toujours du personnel qui reste à bord
qui me permet en fait en cas de problème
technique de pouvoir reprendre la main
et de mettre en œuvre le système en
local à terme mon opérateur sera en fait
à une dizaine de nautiques dans mon
centrale opération en train de piloter
le drone il y a deux configurations
possibles une configuration avec un
sonore remorquée l'avantage qu'il a
c'est que lui tiendra mieux le courant
que l'UV et surtout je vais avoir une
transmission de mes données sonores en
direct dans mon centre opération donc
l'opérateur pourra déjà en temps réel
vérifier la qualité de l'image et si le
fond n'est pas trop encombré arrivé à
identifier immédiatement si il a des
contacts intéressants à aller à
l'identifier sur une configuration ça va
être le drone d'intervention sous-marin
donc un robot en fait qui est donc en
robe qui lui va permettre d'aller
identifier et si l'objet est bien une
mine pour le contreminer en déposant une
charge d'explosif à proximité
à cela s'ajoute de drones sous-marins
autonomes capables de fournir des images
sonarres de haute résolution et multi
angle
[Applaudissements]
l'idée aujourd'hui si vous voulez les
utiliser manifiez
et que vous puissiez restituer aux
industriels qui sont là votre perception
de leur usage et pour vous de d'imaginer
ce que sera le combat de demain on a
fait un exercice ici à l'académie
militaire de Saint-Cyr cookidan avec
l'école militaire interarm en 2021 en
utilisant des robots terrestres en
combat urbain et ces robots ils avaient
une finalité c'est prendre du
renseignement s'exposer détecter
l'ennemi avant que l'ennemi ne puisse
vous détecter et on a fait un certain
nombre de mesures avec les élèves
officiers de l'intérêt quelque part
d'utiliser ces robots est-ce que ça
apporte une plus-value opérationnelle
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu plus long pour le faire
identifié en avance de phase à chaque
fois quasiment donc c'est le côté
positif
déjà bouclier contre le danger le robot
pourrait bientôt avoir sa place au
combat pour voir écouter sentir et agir
plus loin on s'y intéresse pour
l'infanterie par exemple pour réaliser
des investigations de bâtiments voir
s'il y a des présences ennemies à
l'intérieur voir des pièges on envisage
de l'utiliser pour la reconnaissance la
surveillance également peut-être pour le
ravitaillement et pour l'appui au combat
également ce qui paraît vraiment
intéressant c'est de pouvoir exploiter
les capacités complémentaires de l'homme
et de la machine
c'est l'ambition du projet Vulcain porté
par l'état-major de l'armée de terre
la multitude des choses qu'on peut faire
au travers d'une prisme de des robots et
de l'automutilation le champ des
possibles est tellement vaste qu'il a
fallu mettre en place une démarche une
méthode et en fait c'est ça le projet
Vulcain le projet Vulcain c'est à
l'horizon 2040 de disposer d'unités
opérationnelles qui utilisent et
maîtrise l'emploi de systèmes automatisé
dans le combat de demain
une ambition incarnée par la nouvelle
section exploratoire robotique créée à
l'été 2021 et qui rassemble aujourd'hui
17 militaires
l'utilisation des drones et robots
change la façon de penser au niveau de
la manœuvre puisque les missions qui se
faisaient peut-être en une heure sur
fond maintenant en 10 minutes puisqu'on
l'utilisation des drones en avance de
phase pour le renseignement nous permet
d'éviter certaines missions et
d'anticiper aussi sur le futur
en fait pour bien spécifier les futurs
robots les ingénieurs vont notamment à
la DGA ont besoin d'orientation et de
retour d'expérience de la part des
opérationnels et inversement pour
orienter les futurs systèmes les
opérationnels ont besoin de tester des
robots qui soient suffisamment mature et
proches de leurs besoins et donc je
pense que vu le 15 doit permettre de
créer en fait les conditions d'une
boucle vertueuse entre la recherche et
technologies les acquisitions et le
retour d'expérience opérationnelle
historiquement quand on faisait des
expérimentations on s'appuyait sur des
unités diverses qui n'avaient pas
forcément le même ressenti la même
approche de ces systèmes automatisés le
fait d'avoir désormais un point fixe
avec des gens qui ne sont pas des des
expérimentateurs mais bien des
opérationnels spécialisées dans l'usage
des robots nous permet de comparer les
différents systèmes de rendre système
compatibles avec la difficulté du combat
sur le terrain
bravo pour moi j'ai effectué la
reconnaissance du rez-de-chaussée avec
le srmo dans la pièce de gauche j'ai un
ennemi neutralisé je demande
l'autorisation de pénétrer en bâtiment
la section test des robots aéro
terrestres dans des scénarios tactiques
défensifs comme offensifs comme ces mini
robots de reconnaissance obtenue dans le
cadre du programme scorpion qui
renouvelle les équipements de l'armée de
terre
[Musique]
rattaché aux 94ème régiment d'infanterie
la section est localisée à Sissonne dans
l'Aisne au centre d'entraînement aux
actions aux zones urbaines ce camp
dispose d'infrastructures
particulièrement adaptée à l'usage de
robots
en ville on a une vision qui est assez
restreinte et on a des portes
successives par exemple dans des
bâtiments où les risques d'avoir un
piégeage ou des ennemis cachés derrière
sont très fréquents donc l'emploi des
robots a tout son intérêt dans les
souterrains de la même manière on y voit
on y voit très mal il y a des
labyrinthes de tunnels où il peut là
aussi y avoir beaucoup de piégeage
beaucoup d'ennemis cachés et donc là
également les robots peuvent amener une
plus-value très intéressante en évitant
des pertes humaines
personnel ennemi armé détecté
historiquement la ville a toujours été
un point dur pour les pour les combats
avec des rapports de force qui sont
toujours très importants dans ce type de
combat la question que pose le projet
Vulcain c'est est-ce que demain les
systèmes automatisés vont nous permettre
de réduire ce rapport de force grâce à
l'apport de la robotique
pour y arriver des verrous
technologiques restent à surmonter comme
de rendre le robot autonome dans ses
décisions pour les déplacements
un des principaux défis que doivent
relever les industriels aujourd'hui
c'est permettre à ces machines d'avoir
une certaine forme d'autonomie pour
libérer le militaire notamment le
déplacement c'est-à-dire pouvoir donner
à une machine un ordre de déplacement
qu'il puisse exécuter par lui-même c'est
relativement aisé dans les milieux
homogènes que sont les milieux aériens
et sous-marins c'est beaucoup plus
difficile sur le milieu terrestre le
milieu terrestre cumule de très
nombreuses difficultés pour la robotique
terrestre on a une extrême diversité de
l'environnement on a des scènes qui sont
parfois changeantes qui sont très
dynamiques on a aussi des zones qui sont
souvent compartimentées avec
des limitée par des obstacles naturels
artificiels et c'est caractéristique
elles impactent très fortement les
capacités de mobilité les capacités de
communication de réception des signaux
satellites pour la géolocalisation
ou encore le traitement d'image
l'autonomie décisionnel c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très important pour la
robotique et pour pouvoir aller vers une
diversification des applications
ça permet en fait d'éviter par exemple à
l'opérateur de devoir se focaliser sur
la télé opération d'un robot ça permet
de favoriser la discrétion hertine ça
permet également
d'être beaucoup plus fluide pour réagir
aux aléas dans l'environnement
idéalement on aimerait même aller
jusqu'à des interactions en langage
naturel comme on dit donc être capable
de dire au robot
va poster sur la colline en déplaçant de
façon furtive
un gros point positif d'ailleurs que
j'ai vraiment apprécié en position
défensive parce qu'en fait on avait
décelé l'ennemi peut-être deux fois plus
vite que sans les systèmes optiques et
en fait même à un moment on s'est
quasiment retrouvé bloqué parce qu'en
fait les robots les voyaient mais
nous-mêmes à l'oeil nu on n'arrivait pas
à voir l'ennemi quoi dans l'ensemble je
trouve que c'est en tout cas au niveau
tactique en défensif là c'est ça peut
être vraiment une grosse plus-value avec
de telles capacités le robot pourrait
être un pion tactique supplémentaire
dans la manœuvre
pour le chef militaire c'est également
avoir la possibilité d'utiliser
plusieurs robots en même temps bien
évidemment des robots terrestres mais
aussi des robots aériens et là on peut
coordonner divers système combattre de
façon collaborative alors le combat
collaboratif qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
l'autre révolution l'autre game changer
qu'on identifie pour le combat de demain
l'idée c'est d'exploiter la mise en
réseau de l'ensemble des plateformes sur
le champ de bataille et d'optimiser leur
coordination pour accélérer notamment le
tempo de la manœuvre l'objectif c'est de
comprendre de décider et d'agir plus
vite que l'adversaire sur le terrain
la robotisation porte en elle un
potentiel révolutionnaire pour les
armées mais autant d'enjeu éthiques et
juridique
la question de fond c'est la question du
sens de l'action militaire ce sens ne
peut être porté que par l'homme que par
le chef militaire jamais une machine
n'aura conscience de ce qu'elle fait
machine n'est pas un agent moral
quand vous commandez des hommes au
combat il y a une chose primordiale
c'est de donner du sens à leur action
qu'ils comprennent ce qu'ils font
pourquoi ils le font pourquoi ils vont
voyer éventuellement se faire entre les
métros et la peau parce que ça arrive à
nos soldats pour tout pour le style et
qui se font de leur pays de la patrie de
leur drapeau du camarade qui est à leur
côté mais tout ça un robot de l'intègre
pas
un robot n'intègre pas
en 2020 une structure unique au monde
est créée au ministère des armées le
premier comité d'éthique de la défense
dont les travaux doivent servir de guide
dans la conception le développement et
l'utilisation des systèmes d'armes
en matière de robotique le Comité s'est
récemment penché sur la question des
Salah des systèmes d'armes létaux
autonome approuvant le choix fait par la
France dit renoncer
imaginons donc on arrive à faire ce
genre de système coder des fonctions de
décisionnelles de façon à ce qu'il n'y
ait plus intervention de l'être humain
dans l'appréciation de la situation et
dans l'enchaînement avec la décision
faudrait se poser la question qu'est-ce
qu'on est en train de faire là doit-on
le faire voilà et au nom de quoi
commandant à la tête de mon régiment
j'ai eu à te proposer aux rebelles du
moment et il se trouve que les rebelles
du moment avaient les mêmes matériels
que l'armée nationale après au côté de
laquelle nous étions engagés de nuit on
a vu arriver dans nos bras de vision
nocturnes des véhicules
[Musique]
identiques ceux des armées que l'on
était engagés pourrait envers nous avec
des affûts de canon de vin très
dangereux qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce
que c'est un ennemi est-ce qu'on détruit
ou est-ce que c'est éventuellement un
ami paliaison radio etc je n'ai pas tiré
et j'ai attendu le dernier moment et
fort nous n'avons pas tiré parce que
c'était des éléments de l'armée au côté
de laquelle nous convaincutions à
l'époque Assala aurait évidemment tiré
si le système est mal employé etc qui
est responsable finalement est-ce que
c'est effectivement le militaire qui a
pris la décision d'utiliser ce système
peut-être pas dans les bonnes conditions
est-ce que ce sont les concepteurs du
système qui sont en cause est-ce que ce
sont les chercheurs en amont qui sont en
cause etc donc qui est responsable donc
une espèce de dilution de la
responsabilité qui va se produire
en France en tout cas la ligne de
conduite est claire l'humain est et
restera aux commandes de tout système
d'armes ce qui ne signifie pas pour
autant renoncer à la recherche dans le
domaine
nous ne pouvons pas cesser les études
poussant jusqu'au bout la connaissance
de ces armes puisque faut que nos
soldats ne marins puissent se prémunir
contre ces Salins éventuellement
utiliser par d'autres et tant entendu
que les organisations terroristes se
fichent les tirs comme du Gard de
l'éthique et n'hésiteront pas à
éventuellement acheter sur étagère des
armes qui pourraient être des formes de
Salah et de que nous
auquel nous aurions à être confrontés
alors non seulement les réflexions
éthiques en sont pris en compte mais
c'est bien plus que ça en fait ça a été
vraiment le l'accélérateur de la
réflexion sur ce sujet ça nous permet
d'ouvrir le champ des possibles sur ce
qui est réalisable et sur ce qui ne
l'est pas avec cette notion de préserver
la responsabilité du chef militaire dans
les ordres donnés qui soient exécutés
par une unité humaine ou demain par une
unité robotisée
l'apparition des robots armés ou non
téléopérée ou intégrant de l'autonomie
bouleverse la pratique de la guerre
demain ces machines seront autant
d'outil tactiques que d’équipiers sur le
champ de bataille pour le combattant
comme peut-être un nouvel ennemi à
combattre
si de nombreux défis restent à relever
comme les autres pays la France se
prépare à cette mutation en gardant à
l'esprit les mots de l'écrivain Rabelais
sciences sont conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme
[Musique]